Facebook is full of
and we debunk them hey guys I'm off the
grid for August but Mark Zuckerberg half
man half Android Mark Zuckerberg he
still wants to take you into the
metaverse while you're following this
guy I have no idea there was a lot of
attention on Twitter during the election
because of the hunter Biden laptop story
yeah so you guys censored that as well
so we took a different path than Twitter
um I mean basically the background here
is the FBI I think basically came to us
some some folks on our team it was like
hey
um just so you know like you should be
on high alert there was we we thought
there was a lot of Russian propaganda in
the 2016 election we have it on notice
that basically there's about to be some
kind of dump of of um uh that's similar
to that so just be vigilant so our
protocol is different from Twitter's
what Twitter did is they said you can't
share this at all
um we didn't do that what we do is we
have um
if something is reported to us as
potentially
misinformation important misinformation
we we also have this third-party
fact-checking program because we don't
want to be deciding what's true and
false oh my God they're third-party fact
checking program is funded by oligarchs
like Bill Gates and the Rockefeller
Foundation stuff like that's who funds
these third parties that they're The
Establishment so using a fact check be
good in the last uh every fact check
we've ever had on Facebook on one of our
videos has been incorrect meaning
Facebook is wrong they were wrong about
covid they were wrong about the laptop
they're wrong about everything
but now people who know me casually or
know me well and they see when I post
post a video on Facebook and it gets
flagged as misinformation when it isn't
they think Jimmy Dore is up to no good
what's happened to Jimmy Dore no
Facebook is full of
and we debunk them
that's Bill Gates funded fact checking
that's what that is foreign